Je pouvais bouger l'objectif un peu à droite,
vous reculiez et les personnes en arrière-plan ressortiraient.
J'essaie simplement de faire ça ici.
J'essaie de vous donner cette opportunité.
J'essaie de répondre à la question
que mon fils m'a posé.
Je veux faire des peintures,
je veux faire des sculptures
qui sont honnêtes,
qui luttent avec les combats de notre passé
mais évoquent la diversité et les avancées de notre présent.
C'est impossible à faire en effaçant les choses.
Ça ne marchera pas.
Nous devrions le faire de la même façon
qu'avec la Constitution américaine.
Lors d'une situation
où nous voulons changer une loi dans la Constitution,
nous n'effaçons pas l'originale.
À ses côtés se trouve un amendement,
quelque chose qui dit :
« Voici où nous étions, et voici où nous sommes à présent. »
Je pense que si nous pouvons faire ça,
nous serons en mesure de comprendre un petit peu
où nous allons.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)